mica volte in come una vera mangiato un
biscotto della fortuna e mangiato ha
tolto un intero bigliettino ha compreso
vabbè ma avrebbe frugato nelle feci per
sapere cosa diceva ciao ragazzi
bentornate un nuovo video qui sul mio
canale per chi non la conoscesse questa
qui è una rubrica nella quale lancio dei
temi sui social chiedendovi di darmi la
vostra esperienza mandandomi ddm vocali
su facebook
il tema di oggi ho deciso di portare
all'interno dei grandi studios di casa
mia una un ospite internazionale più
unico che raro
forse uno dei genitori più imbarazzanti
presenti sulla faccia di questo pianeta
che mia madre che mi sta guardando dal
termosifone
ma tu recentemente ieri facciano una
cosa eravamo in clinica veterinaria chi
era la dottoressa e una dottoressa
giovane bella e quindi mi è venuto
spontaneo quando l'ho vista ho
dottoressa pure giovane bella hanno
fatto questo commento sia tu che eri con
un commento proprio da vecchia via
benedetto deve poi risparmiare se queste
cose per dire come per dire una
dottoressa addirittura bella e giovane
solitamente quelle belle giovani sono
dei cretini che fa la striscia la
notizia quello che la donazione di la
laurea è riuscita a prendere riusciti a
prendere la laurea droga comunque
partiamo subito ad ascoltare quali sono
stati i vostri commenti
praticamente mio padre racconta ho
sempre raccontato ai miei ragazzi che io
ho presentato sia qualsiasi persona con
i presenti
e da piccolissimo proprio neonata per
farmi andare di corpo usavano stecche
carni con il prezzemolo al balletto
racconta e trans in economia della tua
vita
[Risate]
ma davvero c'è tutto dichiarando questa
cosa il video non era una battuta
e tu pensavi fosse giusto dichiarare
questa cosa il mio video questa sbronza
mostrati infine spaccio e abbiamo un
cortile di casa dentro quale si può
parcheggiare una macchina alla volta ero
davanti casa con il ragazzo e avevo
intenzione di presentarlo in maniera un
po informale a mia madre per la prima
volta deve arrivare mia madre vedo
superare il cortile e improvvisamente la
vedere inserire la retromarcia e entrare
nel cortile a tutta manetta e neanche mi
ha sfondato completamente la macchina
entrando come una matta davanti e non si
sa
secondo me e mia madre pratica il
mettiamo in una nazione o figlia di
questo tipo sono anni catalizzata da
tutte queste invece in mezzo ci sarà
qualcuno che ramagli effettuare un
sistema un bene perché nel giro d'onore
pazienti qualsiasi cosa una volta un
certo consiglio su come la sera il
ragazzo e lui si è presentato a casa e
tra queste c quando abbiamo altri fatto
fatto che le norme lato si secondo legge
lo stipendio
eravamo in vacanza ed elusivo allora un
certo punto di solito treno senza
silenzio è arrivato ai marchi ferragosto
uno dei momenti più romantici della mia
vita con una delle mie storie che
ragazze tutto perfetto
tutto perfetto fuochi d'artificio musica
insomma tutti insieme a urlare e bacio
bacio bacio e ci facciamo fantastico
anche mia madre da lontanissimo da sulla
spiaggia e niente
uno dei momenti più imbarazzanti della
mia vita la mia madre proprietaria di
una macelleria quindi quello che sto per
dire non ha esattamente doppi fini
allora spesso pubblica sue foto con
salsiccia in mano scrivendo su una
decina della salsiccia però dai il fatto
che sia quello che l'ha fatta con le
salsicce di maiale fuga ogni dubbio
riguardo a possibili equivoci scusa a me
e che dovrà farsi le foto
ciao allora di situazioni imbarazzanti
con i miei ne avrei un'infinita però ce
n'è una che non mi scorderò mai
ero al mare con con i miei amici non mi
sono messo alla crema e torna a casa la
sera completamente bruciato soprattutto
in viso arrivo a casa mia madre mi
guarda i mitici subito la caverna
perché la calendula aiuta tra far
passare il bruciore del sole eccetera
eccetera e faccio mamma non ti
preoccupare lo ho già il mio dopo sole
ci penso ci penso io a che mangio inizia
il dopo solo in bagno e poi vado a letto
mi addormento lei con fare da ninja
entra di soppiatto nella mia stanza come
una mamma con in mano già la cannella
con la mano libera mi blocca il braccio
buono e con l'altra con cui aveva già
pronto alla carica stenderla sulla
faccia
il giorno dopo mi alzo e vado in bagno
per lavarsi i denti mi guardo allo
specchio e urlo perché ero giallo non
intendo nina si è fatto nulla attacco il
genitore imbarazzante a mia madre che a
14 anni quindi primo anno di liceo prima
cotta primo compleanno a casa mentre
sono in cucina ma per ragazzo di cui
erano perdutamente innamorata lo guarda
lì fa 46 tizio allora sei tu quello che
fa battere il cuore della mia bambina
attimo di silenzio perché pensi che
possa scattare la casa di questo tipo di
terreno mamma perché odia la figlia
un'adulta pensa cose delicate di bambini
ragazzini va bene e invece non si rende
conto che per una quattordicenne quella
è una cosa enorme grossissima importante
a tutor nei primi 16 mar ma queste due
teenager e niente tramite altri cui
avevo il ciclo è praticamente portata e
mio padre a tutti
non avendo creato un sacco di messaggi
di ragazze che hanno reso la baio che
rivisita la signorina che lo scopre
chiunque e centro di ritardo gli annunci
ultimo giorno di scuole superiori che
mia madre arrivasse in classe con un
cestino pieno di merendine e per ogni
merendina aveva allegato un biglietto
scritto da lei ma ovviamente firmato a
mio nome
scriveva con la speranza di un'amicizia
duratura oppure da parte del tuo nuovo
migliore amico
l'anno scorso la mia mamma mi ha
comprato un asciugamano di quelli con le
scritte e trascritto tutte le mamme
fanno si ribelli ma la via presagi rato
e lo mostrava un grandissimo orgoglio se
non fosse che mia madre mi ha adottato e
io io certamente notare niente solo
imbarazzante ma divertente imbarazzante
se il suo positivo del termine perché
ciò dimostra che i figli sono di chi li
cresce con di crif e mi è piaciuto
pensione o ammazzano bellissimo e
ovviamente cari carina messaggi positivi
sul web e niente ragazzi questo video
finisce qui io ringrazio mia mamma per
avermi permesso di prenderla per il 40
tutti quanti ma soprattutto anche per
aver rubato un pochino del suo tempo per
ascoltare la nostra follia
vi ringrazio naturalmente perché ogni
volta che li modo una call to action su
facebook mi avevano un boato
un boato di di messaggi ed è sempre un
piacere ascoltarli anche se poi alla
fine insomma devo selezionarli e quindi
mi dispiace ecco se non tutti possono
essere accontentati
io vi saluto a questo punto e vi do
appuntamento al prossimo video ciao
bramato studio il dire di farlo ciao 9
facciamoci di montemaggio suo favore
facciamo capito data scherzando